hi guys scifi recapped here
before we start warning
spoilers ahead today i'm gonna explain a
2002 american crime movie called catch
me if you can which is based on the
biography of frank abagnale a con artist
who claimed to pose as a pilot doctor
and prosecutor and forged checks worth
millions of dollars before he got caught
the movie begins with a television
program telling the story of an infamous
con artist frank abagnale jr who
performed various cons in many parts of
the world before his 19th birthday
from 1964 to 1967 he successfully
impersonated a pan-american airways
pilot a chief resident pediatrician at a
georgian hospital and assistant attorney
general at the state of louisiana we
then see carl henrati an fbi agent
tasked to capture abagnale visiting him
in an unnamed french prison he intends
to read to frank the extradition terms
but frank appears to be badly sick his
condition worsens causing carl to
frantically call for medics and deliver
frank to the medical ward frank briefly
escapes but he could not get far as carl
and his men can easily catch up to him
he gave up running and told carl he
wanted to go home
six years earlier frank jr attended a
gala dinner at new rochelle rotary club
where the club president jack barnes
presented frank william abignale senior
his father an honorary member status of
the club
at home frank senior danced with his
wife a french lady named paula and
enthusiastically told his son the story
of how they met which frank jr had heard
a few times the next day frank senior
woke his son up and asked whether he had
a black suit to attend an important
meeting
he persuaded a tailor to borrow a suit
for a military funeral turns out they
were going to chase manhattan bank where
frank sr asked for a business loan but
he was rejected because he was
investigated for tax fraud by the irs
although he claimed that he is not a
criminal and that a bank as big as chase
manhattan would not risk too much in
giving him a loan the bank was firm on
its decision
they moved to a smaller house as they
ran out of money
frank jr also moved school
on his 16th birthday frank senior opened
a checking account for his son to which
he asked why he would open him an
account in a bank that rejected his
request for a loan his father replied
that one day he would find the account
useful
he came to the french class and one of
the school bullies told him he looked
like a substitute teacher to which he
played along
he impersonated his school's french
teacher for weeks giving lessons and
assignments
he even held a parent teacher meeting to
discuss a school field trip
the principal furiously told his
wrongdoing to his parents while frank
waited outside and gave advice to a girl
who forges a doctor's appointment to
skip classes
arriving home frank noticed jack barnes
from the rotary club was visiting
although his father was not at home
he suspected that his mother had an
affair with jack
she gave him some money and let him go
outside
when he came back he found lawyers
already in his house
soon he learned that his parents filed
for divorce and he needed to decide
whose custody he would be put into
devastated by the situation he stormed
off the house headed for the train
station and bought a ticket to the grand
central
to survive frank jr attempted to perform
cons but failed as most of his targets
would not receive checks he then
observed an airline pilot who seemed
famous as people turned their heads when
he walked by and kids asked for his
autograph
he aspired to impersonate a pilot
starting with posing as a student
journalist to interview a real pan am
pilot
he learned important things about being
a pilot including identification badges
useful phrases to talk with other
stakeholders and the topic he was most
interested in paychecks
he then went by the identity of frank
taylor and forged pan am checks to pay
for his life
one day when he wanted to cash a check
he flirted with a teller lady at the
bank
she gladly explained to him the
mechanism of drawing checks at the bank
the micker machine used a special ink to
encode the account numbers to the checks
then the number was routed
frank then purchased a maker encoder
from an auction so he could manipulate
the account numbers by himself
the fbi started to become aware of this
suspicious activity but they have not
figured out his identity
frank jr met with his dad at a fancy
restaurant and bought him a cadillac
however frank senior was afraid that the
irs would become more suspicious of him
driving a cadillac considering his
record with tax frauds he insisted on
taking the train home then frank jr left
he told his dad he was going to
hollywood three fbi agents carl henrati
m dursky and fox were chasing leads in a
hotel
they soon learned frank was still in the
same building and planned an assault
carl went by himself to the hotel room
finding the messy room
frank appeared and introduced himself as
barry allen the secret service agent who
got there first and was also after the
con man
confused carl asked for his
identification but frank distracted him
then he successfully escaped although
carl had known his face and voice
frank met again with the real pan am
pilot he interviewed earlier the pilot
told him about the con artist who had
gone popular in the news dub skyway man
the media even called him james bond of
the sky inspiring frank to become as
cool as james bond in real life
he bought fancy suits and a sports car
when hanging out in a hotel he made out
with a famous model cheryl who was
attracted to him on the night of
christmas eve he called carl at the fbi
office introducing himself as barry
allen he gave carl an address which carl
did not believe was real
carl swore that he would eventually
catch frank after the call ended frank
stepped out of his hotel room which
turned out to be the real address he was
giving to carl earlier meanwhile carl
was studying his leads at a diner when a
waiter accidentally saw his papers and
asked if he was a comic book fan because
he saw barry allen the real name of the
flash superhero character on his papers
carl deduced that the con man he was
after was only a kid because he used
comic book references
after filtering potential suspects he
visited paula's house and finally
identified frank's face from his old
yearbook photo they then knew the
identity of the con artist frank
abagnale jr
meanwhile frank already changed his
identity to frank connors a medical
doctor after he met a naive nurse brenda
strong at a hospital
he forged his graduate certificate from
harvard medical school and applied as a
pediatrician at a hospital brenda worked
in
he gradually fell in love with brenda
when they started to make out in his
office he was called to the emergency
room
he threw up at the sight of blood and
recited conversations from a medical
documentary he watched earlier on the
other hand carl visited frank senior and
noticed the letters he received from his
son
he retrieved an address from atlanta
georgia and immediately headed there
with his team
fortunately the apartment was empty at
his new apartment frank was making out
with brenda
she told him she was kicked out of her
house after she had an abortion years
ago
frank decided to help her by meeting her
parents and asking for their permission
to marry her he learned that brenda's
father was a lawyer so he crafted a
story that he was a lawyer who practiced
law for a year before he went to medical
school brenda's father seemed attracted
to frank's background
brenda even begged her father to let
frank work for him as it was very
difficult for him to find an assistant
prosecutor
somehow frank's charm convinced brenda's
family he passed the bar exam and got
the job at her father's office
now that he was engaged he met his
father again to invite him to his
wedding he already arranged first-class
airline tickets and expensive suits for
him to wear but frank senior seemed
disappointed having no one to talk to
frank called carl again
he asked carl to stop chasing him as he
wanted to marry and settle down but carl
would not let that happen
knowing that frank would not be able to
change his name or he would risk his
engagement carl searched for an
engagement announcement from a man named
frank connors carl and his team came to
frank and brenda's engagement party
hosted by brenda's parents
frank realizing he might get caught
desperately told brenda the truth and
escaped with a bunch of cash just before
carl got to him
he instructed brenda to meet him in two
days at the miami international airport
and they would fly away and live
together however when brenda got there
exactly at the designated time he
noticed undercover fbi agents all around
her and refused to come out of his car
he drove away leaving brenda puzzled at
the airport knowing that the airport was
heavily guarded and there seemed to be
no way he would board a plane unnoticed
frank used his pilot identity to host an
on-campus stewardess recruitment program
and recruited eight beautiful girls to
draw the police's attention while he
sneaked his way to the plane bound for
spain
the investigation continued
the fbi learned that frank used real
printed checks that only a few places
could produce
in europe one of those places is france
carl remembered his interview with paula
who told him she came from the french
village of monreshar he chased frank to
france and found him in a printing
facility where he printed all his forged
checks
he did not believe carl was really going
to capture him but after stepping out of
the facility he was immediately captured
by police and transferred to a french
prison
carl and frank are now on a plane
approaching new york frank reminds carl
of his promise to call his father once
he lands but carl replies that his
father is dead after tripping off the
stairs
frank is devastated by the news and
locks himself inside the airplane's
lavatory then escapes and runs to
paula's house
he observes from the window that his
mother has married jack and has a little
daughter frank then surrenders to carl
and is sentenced to 12 years in prison
sometimes carl visits frank and tells
his stories at work frank occasionally
helps carl with leads on fraud checks
later carl tasks frank to work with the
fbi helping with fraud checks so his
sentence may potentially get reduced
frank agrees but does not find himself
very comfortable at office work
he plans to use his pilot identity to
fly away carl meets him at the airport
and surprisingly lets him perform as
khan as no one will chase him he is
convinced that frank will come back on
monday to the fbi office again which he
does subscribe to watch more videos like
this turn on notifications and leave a
like to help the channel out thank you
for watching